and this is probably
to do something because most of the
fears in
have to do with not being able to
predict for instance
the cue that you fear and with not being
able to control it
so with uncontrollability and with
unpredictability
and that's why these insects moving fast
and
somehow yeah you feel probably like i
i want to control them i want to control
the the noise or that they come to me
and you can't so this is really then
what you need in the treatment
to feel that uh
in order to target your fear memory
what compelled you to make this
documentary the cure to fear at
documentary
yeah first of all uh the documentary
there are more
documentaries so first the memory
hackers
there's a treatment was a nofa
documentary and then this
um the science of fear by uh roberto
ferdecchia that is uh
be afraid the signs of fear that was
broadcasted
in canada actually cbs
they approached me so not vice versa
and the same old for lana wilson
but yeah i think
um to first
to uh educate people that uh
that there are millions of people that
suffer
from crippling fears and phobias so to
to to teach people that they are not
weak or crazy that they have these fears
that that is very important
but also to educate them about all the
mysteries of emotional memory which is i
think
for everyone a very relevant and
intriguing topic
great um i'd like to ask a couple of
technical questions if i may
um regarding your research in your
illuminating 2009 paper
and you briefly discussed two theories
uh namely
you know the there was the storage
theory as well as the retrieval theory
one of which you surmised may have
caused a fear of memory extinction
however at the time it was not clear
which one
was the cause would you please a little
bit elaborate on these
theories and furthermore tell us whether
11 years later
now in 2020 do we have a better
understanding of the mechanism behind
memory extinction
from a let's say theoretical perspective
or is it still
largely a mystery overall no well
if you only study humans it is almost
at least very hard and almost impossible
to to disentangle between a retrieval
problem or a storage problem whether you
really
change the underlying memory trace or
whether you it's difficult
it's more difficult to retrieve it but
maybe it's still there but you can
just retrieve it and
clinically i mean if the retrieval
difficulty is is so huge that you can
never retrieve it anymore
then it doesn't make any difference but
theoretically it's of course very
interesting
from the animal literature well now that
we are more and more able to
find actually the memory engram in the
brain
by optogenetics and so on and that means
that you can turn
on and off the fear memory
they also showed that the
reconsolidation
intervention really changed the memory
engram
and this suggests at least that it
affects the storage